from a distance
it can all seem very silly these people
have gone to lords
in the foothills of the pyrenees in the
hope that the virgin mary
might cure them of cancer and heart
disease
these people have gone to medjugorje in
bosnia and herzegovina to pray that they
might get a chance to talk to dead
beloved relatives
and these people are praying at the
western wailing wall of the old jewish
temple in jerusalem and leaving all
sorts of notes for god to read in the
cracks between the stones
no wonder some atheists just think the
whole of religion
is ludicrous and they aren't bothered
about saying so very directly
but that's the wrong way to look at
religion what religion teaches us isn't
about what's
true but about what many of us here on
earth desperately
want to be true for some pretty
understandable reasons
at one point in the bible jesus goes
into the house of a man called jairus
whose 12 year old daughter has just died
everyone is weeping and lamenting
but jesus calmly says that she's not
dead she's just asleep
little girl i say to you get up he says
we shouldn't laugh or dismiss the whole
thing as nonsense
when your child is very sick you may
well end up believing in miracles
because at the end of the day under
immense psychological pressures
you love your child more than you care
about the laws of
physics and biology and when your loved
ones do die
it can take a very robust mind indeed
not to imagine late at night when the
sadness becomes
overwhelming that somehow your parent or
child or friend is somewhere still
around in a better place than they were
and that they might be able to see us as
we go about our daily lives and
forgive us and understand what we
perhaps never found a way
to say to them and when you're in a
complete mess and all you want to do is
cry in shame
you might well start to long for someone
who could understand someone wise and
forgiving
with kindly sympathetic eyes who won't
judge and will be patient and kindly
like an ideal mother science may very
rightly deny the existence of the virgin
mary
let alone paradise and miracles but
these beliefs
shouldn't just be interpreted as pieces
of stupidity
they are signs of extreme emotional
distress and desperation
which should rightly elicit in us
understanding and
sympathy religious beliefs are of course
technically false
but they're coming from a very tender
and vulnerable place
which needs our empathy of course
atheists are
technically right but there's no point
getting maddened by the apparent
irrationality of the religious we have
to understand it
and appreciate the intensity of the
longings that lead some of us to believe
in fantasies
against all odds because reality is
sometimes
just unbearably painful
you